this time scott
and i are filling in some some gaps you
know most of the time we've been talking
about
the british scenes or various american
scenes now are going over to
europe and we're going to do another uh
thing specifically on like a broader
picture of european metal because it's
obviously not all germany but this time
we're focusing
in on germany and in part um
the motivation for this is as
metalheads who grew up in the 70s and
80s
there were there were two german bands
early on
who were a major part of the metal scene
outside of germany and that was first
the scorpions and then
accept and then there were other bands
as well obviously that that played a big
role
but those two you know if you think
about like
a vinyl collection or you know riding
around in somebody's car and the tapes
that used to be in those tape
cassette holders and and what would be
the representative stuff in there like
you'd have an iron maiden one
and a judas priest one and maybe rat but
you'd have the scorpions and you'd have
accept at least you know
balls to the wall or you know worldwide
live or
you know love it for sting or something
like that so they were they were in that
that sort of um framework we can say
but there is also a german distinctively
german
metal scene that's developing you could
say
really in the mid to late 70s and then
well into the 80s and then there's as we
were talking about before we got started
there is this massive explosion of all
different metal
bands and types of metal and i think
there's a lot of you know
interconnections between that what was
going on also in scandinavia
which deserves its own treatment so that
that's why we wanted to do
this particular session
and german you know german metal can be
viewed as part of a larger
european scene but as we're going to
talk about
the key players in this also conceived
of what they were doing
as being something global something
not distinctively german or as they like
say teutonic
right now it's a little bit different i
want to say one proviso before we jump
into this
it's a little bit different with the
german thrash scene
where you know in the early 80s you've
got some
pretty important bands and there is a
distinctive sound but it's not just
distinctive
it's not just confined to germany
austria
even the czech at that time
czechoslovakia
there's some back and forth stuff and uh
switzerland play
play a role in that um so we're going to
do a whole
discussion of that when we talk about
thrash metal and some other
some other session um so
you know if you if you're if you think
where is that stuff that's
that's why we're putting that off um you
know the german metal scene
for those of us like i mentioned who
grew up in the 70s and 80s and i see
that we have some
members here uh who definitely fit that
demographic profile
it's uh it's one that was familiar to
metal heads in in
that time but it was also in many
respects
the ins and outs of it were unknown
scott and i were talking about this
yesterday
in another conversation the difference
between the
access that we have to bands today
through the internet
or even before that you know when there
was a lot more music
reporting compared to say the early 80s
you really had no idea what was going on
with these bands you know circus and hit
parader
or if you were able to get carang or
something like that
but we couldn't get that in the drug
stores where i got my music magazines
you know as scott was pointing out to me
yesterday those articles were like
pre-approved you weren't going to get a
lot of
inside dope you know or interviews that
are very revealing
and where i grew up you know i would i
would go to this this record store
in brookfield square and they had one
single section for metal imports
and that was where you'd find out about
these bands that you didn't you know
you'd never heard of
and you know you'd look at the album
cover and that would tell you a bit
you'd look at the back and it would be
like song titles
but you'd be like i don't know if this
is any good or not and you know the
imports were usually kind of expensive
so i didn't i didn't buy a lot
i got exposed to some of these bands
through tape swapping
through people that i knew saying hey
man you should listen to this you know
and and they had a better collection
than i did and i don't what was it like
for you scott
in terms of like getting i mean
obviously the scorpions we heard them on
the radio right
and except you'd sometimes hear them on
the radio but what about these
did you have any exposure to these other
bands at all or
you know it's interesting my stories i
grew up in a town that didn't have mtv
we didn't have cable
okay so i was the only metal head in my
school
so everybody was a deadhead in you know
the 80s they were all like into neil
young and
if you went to a party neil young would
be playing and
i was the only one buying like you know
the def leppard records and all this
stuff from the people that were on mtv
but the scorpions were on mtv
yeah of course and um
so unfortunately there wasn't a lot of
tape swapping for me
um because nobody listened to metal in
my school so i was
there was one guy uh one one kid that uh
listened to metal a lot and
actually uh he he was good at kind of
like he would bring me a tape once in a
while actually
he was the only one and he would say hey
this is the new whatever
and i go home but you know i guess the
difference between then and now
is i'd listen to it but i'd want my own
copy so i'd
you know oh yeah i'd mow the lawns and
you know it was like
were seven or eight bucks back then yeah
so i got my eight bucks went you know i
had my mom dream
bring me when i was like not old enough
to drive and we would uh i get that
record and i just you know
that was a a badge of honor back then
it's very different now
yeah you know this is another thing that
you and i were talking about
yesterday in sort of our pre-show
conversation
yeah um and i think pretty much
everybody in our
our audience right now can relate to
this as well when you got a new
album you listen to the whole thing or a
new new tape right you
you listen to the whole thing it wasn't
today we're in a very different sort of
format where
um people are you know i'll stream this
song and maybe it'll be part of a
playlist or something but they won't
necessarily
listen to an entire album and they won't
do it attentively necessarily you know
it it might be
while multitasking and um you know
there was less going on
not to not to stop you i'm sorry but um
yeah go ahead consider the fidelity i
mean um and i've said this in past shows
where you know um with
our age group you know the 70s and 80s
the well the um the um what do you call
the standard was having the receiver the
turret
the tape deck the nice speakers so when
you bought an album you heard the low
end you had the bass guitar you heard
everything
and now people will like just listen to
it like on an mp3 format which is
far enough through headphones like
earbuds or just on their phone
yeah they'll just play their phone and
um you know that was maybe our am radio
i guess but am you know was like you
know low five
or or are walkmans you know um those
were great the walkmans was analog
tape and right yeah the fatter the sound
got
um and now with digital if you turn mp3s
up you just ruin your hearing
okay yeah the listening experience is
different of course
but um but i think that's that's kind of
the thing now it's you know
not to not to hijack this for a second
into technology but
um this is a you know sore point with me
but it's like
technology's uh in the music is
convenience over quality
so you know yeah and there's another
aspect of this too
that's a broader topic you don't know
what you don't know
a lot of the time and so if you
if you haven't been exposed to hearing
music in a format that has
you know like the low end and a higher
fidelity
you don't know what you're missing right
you think that well that's just that's
just
it and actually i think a lot of bands
could suffer as a result you're playing
their stuff you're like why i don't know
why p why do people say that they're
good you know it doesn't sound that good
to me
so that could be a significant issue and
also the trend of
um you know speaking of german bands i
was telling greg
yesterday that um i had the accept live
album
with udo from 85 which would be the
metal heart tour i'm pretty
sure right yeah so
um i lost the cd you know uh and so i
re-bought it
but it came with two cds the whole show
um
and listening to that cd from back in
the day they didn't over
compress what i mean is so if you
compress
if you take an album and mix it um
they master the album now what happened
in the last
10 maybe 15 years is the anr
guy or woman um would say i want
our band to be louder than the other
bands
and so what would they do they would
over compress the album and it becomes
white noise i don't know if anybody's
bought a record in the last or a cd in
the last
10 years and it's kind of like no matter
where it is
you hear white noise it's over
compressed and
um getting that live show i could turn
my stereo up because i have i have a
volume knob
and it even with the cd it was just fat
and warm and
and so the trends themselves are just
kind of like
uh it became a volume war you know i was
just reading
uh an interview in today with one of the
band
band members of one of the bands that
we're going to
look at shortly and he was talking about
the new wave of traditional heavy metal
and why that's taking off and
also i'm going to read it right here
this is marcus berger of the band
trance which was at one time looked at
as like one of the big three
we we think of scorpions except but
trance was
sort of poised to become as important as
as them in terms of uh german heavy
metal
so he said uh here's the question what
do you think about the renewed interest
for a traditional heavy metal
it seems a new golden age for this kind
of music and burger said
it's a logical result and a stream
against the power
overdosed in high compressed new metal
music
even the hardest rock song has to
breathe
and show many facets of emotion to stay
long time interesting after it's blown
you away by first listening
also the modern drop tuning of the
guitars gives a different darker feeling
to the music
traditional heavy metal doesn't need
these tricks and gives you a much more
powerful positive and high feeling just
with normal
tuning and i think there that that's a
very interesting
set of reflections right go ahead
fantastic you had that
queued up no i mean i agree i mean
um you know all the bands well you know
with the german bands scorpions
worldwide live the um
the i had the vinyl and i was the louder
i turned it up at my parents house when
i was young
that must have been a treat for them and
the neighbors
but i was playing air guitar so um but
it was an experience i would say
so um but now like you know you play
something on your cell phone it's in the
background it's like yeah and
um but you know i try to tell people
it's kind of like the experience
aspect it's not over compressed there's
room to breathe with dynamics
well even take deal for example you know
like a
last in line it starts off kind of soft
and then when it builds
you hear it go up yeah um or um
um well what's the scorpion's ballad
that came out on love at first thing
um is it still loving you or was that on
blackout
no that's still loving you you're right
and so i remember
having that record and it started off
soft and then
it would get louder so it wasn't
compressed in the sense that
what dynamics yeah right so the
compression gets rid of the dynamics
um you know there there's a couple songs
on that particular album
um the one that is i think at the very
end of the album
i'm blanking on the name of it but it
starts out with
uh just the just the guitar and a soft
drumming
um crossfire i think living in the
crossfire
um there's a few there's a few songs on
that album that are that are doing that
that are playing with dynamics quite
well
and metal of course i mean especially in
that era
um well you don't want to hear something
that um
when it's soft it's as loud as when the
band builds up
so i think you know that quote is great
that you had
up i would love to hear more of that
from these artists
um yeah i mean let's let's actually talk
so we're going to come back to some
other issues that we had sort of on the
docket lined up
um but actually let me also take this
comment from mark two he says if i could
afford all the equipment i'd love to
start a vinyl collection
um i think wouldn't we all but
it's expensive isn't it to do that oh go
ahead scott
um i mean it was expensive it's
as expensive as it was before so like i
my turntable is called u-turn audio
and they're made in cambridge mass
they're only a couple hundred bucks but
they're very high-end
um so it's kind of like i get it
like you know i just mark i just want to
go back to the
technology being more convenient not
better
so um it's cheaper it's faster
and you know like now they want you know
like the like the cell phones want you
to like
have your credit card so you could just
go boop yeah
phone and you could buy something it's
like well that's not necessarily
a good thing um
especially if you're not disciplined in
your spending
but i mean i think the deal is um we had
different um so we didn't have thousand
dollar
iphones back in the 80s right so we
weren't
you know i think it's uh as far as this
goes
it's it's where we uh find
our dollar to be important so if you're
if like say you and i want to get the
experience of like
you know the scorpion's blackout or
michael shanker you know his first album
well we'd have to invest in a system to
do that which wasn't a problem in the
80s
but now with all this technology with a
laptop and all this and we could do all
this
it's more convenient but it's not it's
it's not
giving you the experience you know part
of what's what's also missing is the
you could i mean you could listen to
stuff by yourself but there was also the
communal aspect of hey man i got this
new album come on over to my place and
let's listen to it you know
um that that i think is is um
that's kind of missing right mark has
another question here
what do you think of people uploading
vinyl rips onto youtube does it make a
difference
that's that's interesting because
actually a lot of stuff
on youtube with a lot of stuff with with
bands that are not particularly well
known that's where you find it is on
youtube right
um yeah i so
there's a few things to speak about this
is a great question by the way mark
thank you
um so first of all as far as the sonic
experience you're not getting it
you know um it would be like uh it would
be interesting
if you were interested in buying the
record you could get us a vibe of what
the album's about
um and greg and i were talking yesterday
that you know
um i'm in a fight with a certain
distribution that put all of my albums
on youtube without my permission
and they're collecting they're
collecting the revenue from the ads
although
as greg and i joked hardly anyone's
listening to them so
but um yeah i mean we're talking about
intellectual property we're talking
about like you know
twenty thousand thirty thousand dollar
investment
that went into making the albums and now
it's like well it's all for free because
that's a mentality now but the flip side
is
um you're not getting the experience so
if i hear something on youtube for
example like oh check out the new
whatever record
like say the scorpions put up out a new
record of michael shanker
um you might want to hear like basically
generally what's going on but then i
would purchase it because
i mean that's the experience to me it's
not like i'm trying to support
anyone it's just yeah i guess that was
our thing back then
it was our pleasure yeah fork over the
money and we couldn't wait to get the
vinyl and show our
shop to our friends you know like when
motley crue's album shot of the devil
came out like
one kid in our school had it we all want
to go over his house and hear it you
know
this is a total side note but like i
remember when i was in high school
when somebody did get like a new tape or
a new
um album they often would bring it to
school and
they'd like show it off they'd be like
look at this you know
and everyone would be like oh that's so
cool you know let me take a look at it
you know
and then after a while they'd be like
okay pause off you know i don't want it
to get all grimy and stuff did that that
well i mean you said your school you
were the one of the few metalheads so
obviously that wasn't happening right oh
mark asked i'm sorry a follow-up
question
i i didn't answer your question i
apologize no so what happens is
if you rip from a cd or vinyl it gets
compressed down to an mp3 so no matter
what the quality was
it goes down to an mp3 which is far
inferior i guess it would be like
if we took the mona lisa and did a
photocopy of it and a photocopy
and a photocopy of it and a photocopy of
it um
it's not it's still it's like it's like
the people who go
to the louvre right and then they have
their iphones out i've seen
i've seen this they like you have to
like shuffle up to get to the mona lisa
because it's tiny
and then they're like snapping these
these pictures and
you're gonna frame them yeah but it's
not the experience of seeing
you know like with painting there's
texture there's all this stuff
um that people you know i
a side note i was doing a session about
eight years ago and there was a painting
in the studio
that i really loved and i asked the
person you know i said
is this first would you sell that to me
like i'd like to buy that
it was a cool painting and uh he's like
no no no i like it i'm not gonna sell it
so the drummer went up and took a
picture of it he goes yeah there now
just go to the like kinko's and gavin
frame
but that kind of is not quite the same
isn't it
well it's not the same but also kind of
offended me like you know
not only are musicians but artists are
like the whole i'll take a screenshot of
this
and then i'll send it to kinko's and get
something and then i have that work but
it's
it's not the same experience i've seen
the texture and the
uh the actual color right so anyways
mark that was a really good question
because
vinyl cd you can't really tell once it
goes down to
mp3 which is a a very inferior
uh format yeah well so mp3 the
the the point of mp3 is you can fit
thousands of them on on
your phone and or your computer and the
reason and
so what they have to do is they have to
make them small files yeah yeah
so as you turn it up you get a headache
your ears ring
so it's interesting so you know when
mp3 players started you know becoming a
big thing
it really was a matter of convenience
and people were bragging oh i've got
like 500 songs
right now and now it'd be like 500 songs
that's nothing you know
um but yeah we've got we've gotten kind
of
kind of trapped into that right well
it's interesting yeah
it's it's it's a great conversation
because um
you know we were promised a lot of
things in the late 90s
musicians were promised you'll reach
audiences around the world
people more people will hear your music
you'll sell more yeah
and what happened as a result is we have
very low quality
we have uh singles and people you know
uh you might remember you buy love at
first sting
by the scorpions you put it you put the
needle on and you listen to it the way
they intended you to listen to it
with the songs in the order they were
put in and
now it's just kind of like this single
this single this playlist
um we lost the art of the album which
was which was
of essentially a story you know if you
go to like queen's rank operation mind
crime
well you can't really get the experience
unless you listen to the movie yeah if
you were to listen to that on shuffle
that doesn't make much sense right any
concept album
but let's we should jump into talking
about the uh
development of of metal so i i wanted to
focus on
some early let's call them early mid 70s
bands the ones that were
viewed as really making a big
contribution then we'll start veering
off into others
and there are some topics and issues
that we want to bring up
for example we're not going to talk
about it right this second but
like why did english become the lingua
franca for
metal when there was like a strong
let's sing in german scene in in other
genres so um scorpions are absolutely
central right
and you can you can look at them as
being
not just a band in their own right but
also spinning off a few
other things you know when we talk about
michael schechner he gets his start in
the scorpions
jumpship for ufo comes back to play on
love drive a bit and then you know
launches his
his own band which is uh you know
scott and i were talking about this and
scott was saying that's more you could
call it more european metal than german
metal but
it's um as far as genre yeah yeah
and then you've got levon roth you know
uh
very important early guitarist after
michael schechner with the
scorpions who did some solid work and
then goes off and
founds his own uh band which which is
still around today
but so the scorpions um the backstory
you know i think a lot of people know
the scorpions from their 1980s stuff but
they
they really take off in in the 70s and
that sets the stage for that
um officially you can say they were
founded in 65 but they weren't really
founded in 65 that's rudolph schechner
doing his thing and then by 1970
his younger brother um michael joins
and and you know a word of advice too
michael does a lot of interviews
where he tells a lot of stories about
the original founding and how rudolph
didn't have any talent that's clearly
false you know oh yeah um but in any
case
klaus mine and rudolph joined at that
time and they they managed to
bring out one album lonesome crow which
if any of you have ever listened to
it's kind of jazzy there's some metal
stuff in there
nobody was calling it metal at the time
and then
michael leaves and the band effectively
breaks up
and what we know as the scorpions is
actually scorpion's mark ii
what what happened was rudolf schechner
got in with this other band called dawn
dawn road
and he was you know jamming with them
and playing with them and
he joins that band and brings klaus mina
in there
and then effectively takes over the band
um they changed the name to the
scorpions because
the scorpions was already a successful
name and nobody had heard of dawn road
so it's it's sort of like with deep
purple you've got the purple mark 1 and
mark ii this is scorpion's
mark ii and then they release fly to the
rainbow
which if you've ever listened to there
are some metal songs on there
there's also some like psychedelic
trippy stuff
that was the era where you know the
world was exploding i i say the world
yeah
um classical composers in europe
and america like philip glass or
stockhausen
um everything blew up in the 60s maybe
because of the socially but you hear it
in rock albums like i think i told you
the weird pink floyd thing i saw in like
nix
where the the guy the british guy the
bbc guy was like this isn't my cup of
tea but the kids seemed to like him
and it was completely psychedelic and
experimental yeah
but i think that you would hear that
with all the german bands as well it's
kind of like
what if we did this what if we made the
sound possibilities
yeah and so this is kind of a side note
here
um these early german heavy metal bands
look us looking back at them they did
not view themselves as heavy metal bands
until
later so you hear this from
you know rudolph schenckner for example
on klaus mina
you hear this clearly in udo talking
about it he was asked in an
interview recently were you part of a
heavy metal scene and he's like
there wasn't a heavy metal scene we
became the heavy metal scene what we
were is part of hard and heavy rock and
that's how they conceptualized
themselves
which allowed for a greater you know
if you're doing heavy metal there's a
sense in which well you got to do this
stuff but don't do this stuff over here
right and so it allowed i think for a
greater artistic freedom
um than then uh maybe if they you know
started in the 1980s and self-identified
as heavy metal
um and also remember like the
progression of music history
um certain things didn't exist when
these bands came out right
yeah so i mean you and i joke all the
time like you know i have
i have students that like you know to to
all of us here heavy metal is one thing
maiden dio but now it's like well is it
you know uh is it this genre of that
genre all right if there's like
probably a hundred sub-genre genres is
it like
math rock is it math metal is it
norwegian death metal is it norwegian
black metal and like
i'm just thinking like why are you what
happened to just metal
but you know yeah i mean
and and i think that that only worked
until metal became very successful and
then
by the mid 80s people really are making
distinctions you know i mean
think about um the animus that thrash
so we're talking about you know mid to
early 80s thrash people had
against what they would call pop metal
or metal light or
you know right that big designation of
hair metal
you know think about how you know we're
going to talk about this in a bit
the notion of speed metal what exactly
is that right
that was not a stable genre but accept
was viewed as
being like absolutely central to it as
was
motorhead and raven you know
um and and you know you could say well i
play speed metal today but nobody would
actually know what you mean
you know that's well be another speed
metal band
that got identified with a canadian band
you know well anthrax was because
double kick drums it was like i remember
that when anthony came out like people
said it was speed metal
that's interesting because i so this
might be a regional thing
i get introduced to them as hey here's
another thrash band
you know oh yeah but yeah i mean maybe
that these genre things are kind of
unstable until
until they become kind of ossified later
on
by like the mid 90s and people are like
i do this kind of metal you know i do
not do this kind of metal
and i hear it all the time it's like you
know i'll ask a student first off like
you know what do you
what do you identify as a player right
now yeah what are your goals and they'll
always have something
it's like a paragraph instead of just
metal it's
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah metal yeah
like you know there's like uh uh
like you know ten words that become or
adjectives that become
that come before the word metal and i'm
like all right i'm not gonna
they're those are those are qualifiers
yeah i mean if
we're thinking in terms of like grammar
and philosophy what those
do effectively ideally
i should say because there's always a
lot of messiness to this
is they they define for us the range of
what we're looking at you know right um
and and
in many areas of life that can be
extremely useful i mean you go to the
hardware store
you don't want there to be any
loosey-gooseyness about
the kind of equipment that you're
picking out but i think in artistic
areas
it can often become an impediment for
both both producers but also for
consumers you know
yeah i mean uh well if you think about
let's go back to the 80s if you wanted a
record store
um there'd be rock jazz blues classical
and it might be a metal section you know
maybe
um if it's a big enough star right a lot
of it like you'd find the scorpions and
iron maiden under rock
yeah in the early yeah but um
you know record stores don't so much
exist now um
but you know i i'm always curious would
what would accept go under what would
the scorpions go under
well it's interesting because if you
look at apple music
right which does have these categories
preserved in it they do have a metal
category but a lot of the bands that we
consider to be metal are actually
under rock rather than metal it seems
yeah it seems like metal is
the way that apple music understands it
is more for the
later genres right mark
mark says something here so your this
would be a great one for you to field
uh scott genres are for the audience not
the artists
what do you think no absolutely because
um
i remember john harrington is a guitar
player from new york
um and he was doing this
thing with mark egan from pat matthini
group and all this and it was
you know people would call it fusion
okay it was it was eclectic and i'll
never forget they
they asked him they said um well what
are you what is this music we're hearing
he goes i never thought about it why do
you want to put a label to it
so they're not thinking so i agree it's
kind of like you make the music you want
to make
and then the record companies say well
we need to know where to file this
right so or they put or they put
pressure on you
some of the times on the record well
this this thing is really getting trendy
so can you sound more like this
you know genre is for the audience
as far as like well you know like we get
the thing like uh
what's the most classic cliche is uh i
like all music except country
you know or i like this but like um
so it's it becomes kind of a um i think
the audience identifies
i've always noticed people identifying
with i don't like country because i'm
not the kind of person or i don't like
metal because i don't like that i'm not
that kind of person but for the bands
themselves i don't think
um that's a good point i mean when i
make music
personally um i don't care what you call
it i don't know what to call it
you know it's just i hope you like it
you know
um but that's a really good point
because
um i think you and i have talked in the
past you know if you identify as a metal
person well the
like the one other person in my school
we identified together
like buds and we connected through the
metal
label yeah that was a really really
important
aspect of um say 1970s
1980s maybe going into the 1990s um
the metal scene was that camaraderie
that would come about
of being into the same kind of
band's look um maybe lifestyle
you know i mean some of that part wasn't
particularly good i mean you know
a good bit of like pretending to be much
more aggressive or stupid than you
were to fit in on my part at least
um yeah yeah yeah the jean jacket
we always talk about the patches and
stuff yeah yeah
what packages make it on your jean
jacket yeah and you know what are what
are you actually like scribbling on your
on your folders
you know or or in my case my jeans um
but let's come back to the talking about
the scorpions yes and this and this
scene so
you know uh i mentioned two early albums
you know lonesome crow and fly to the
rainbow
by the time that we get to in trance and
that's 1975
and then virgin killer taken by force
these are the ulivon roth
albums it's definitely metal it's it may
not be identified as such by the
scorpions or by
some of the the listeners they they
might be more willing to say
it's just heavy rock man you know but um
it's it's clearly within the metal
spectrum and it's being played on the
same kind of radio stations
that you know say deep purple
or black sabbath or the other bands like
that or judas priest
are going to be played on and you know
you look at this and
and the the notion of like heavy metal
the
this is going to be a little bit of a
rant on my part rob helford
i love the guy but he's got this um this
narrative that's clearly false about the
the development of heavy metal where
first it was black sabbath
and maybe deep purple was doing
something as well and then it was this
long wasteland until judas priest came
around in 1975
scorpions were doing metal in 75. you
know other other bands were too we've
talked about this before but
you know this this is clearly uh a sign
of that
and then you know after that they keep
churning out more and more stuff and
they are really
the powerhouse you could say of of
german
heavy metal um and then there's there's
a couple other bands i mean we mentioned
except we
really uh have to credit them as being
like the second
most definitive german early metal band
um they're formed officially in 76 but
there's a kind of backstory to that
there was another band with that udo
dirk schneider was in called band x
that you know developed into
accept in some ways wolf hoffman managed
to
get some of the legal rights to things
in part because his at that time
girlfriend then later
wife was doing a good bit of the
songwriting and also
managing the the band uh and then the
real core of the band
early on was wolf hoffman uh udo dirk
schneider peter baltas on base
um you know people like herman frank
would come in later
um but you know they went through some
transitions with with drummers and with
um guitarists and their their first
album is
is 79 so it's right on that cusp you
know when when we're about to see the
new wave of british heavy metal
except comes on the scene and they're
they're like identified as
as a speed metal um i'm a rebel is
1980 breakers is uh 81
restless and wild 82 balls to the walls
83 so they're just churning out records
yeah yeah wow
and they're getting heavier and heavier
um they also
i will mention on breaker there's a song
called son of a [ __ ]
which is uh unplayable on
on radio stations because it's basically
just a bunch of swears put together
um to try to stick it to the record
company because then they're already
ticked off at that but there's a couple
other bands that we should mention that
people might not have heard of i i
talked about trance a little bit earlier
they they formed in the mid 70s
and they didn't actually secure an album
contract until the 80s they have
breakout and
power infusion in 82 and 83 and then
victory in 85.
if you haven't heard them they're worth
listening to
it's it's solid heavy metal um
they were poised to to really break out
and they got
and they ended up getting screwed by
their manager um
and uh eventually they they
worked things out but they were caught
in a lawsuit for a long time i'll
mention another thing too
those three bands all three of them
there was a
really important producer uh dieter
dirks who
who had his own studio who produced you
know the scorpions and accept
and in and and trance was supposed to
work with jerks but he was too busy with
these other bands
had that happened we might be talking
about them
in the same way that we do uh scorpions
and accept
there was another band as well that's
worth actually two bands that are worth
mentioning in this this period too
so one was called kakumen and if you
haven't heard of them that's because
they changed their name to bonfire and
they're still around today
and the reason that they changed their
name is because nobody had any idea what
the hell they
they were supposed to mean it's sort of
like with in in american metal
syrup ungul you know uh it's a cool name
but nobody knew how to pronounce it or
what it was supposed to be
and then and they felt that hell that
held them back so they made a deliberate
choice to change their name
they they did record um three things
under the the name of kakumen riding
away which was a single and then a
self-titled album cockerman and then bad
widow in the early 80s so they're part
of the metal scene as well
and then i think maybe some of some of
us here
know um running wild and if we do
it could be because of their early stuff
or it could be because they are the
not the only originators but probably
the most important originators of pirate
metal
a genre that consists in you know
singing about the sea
and piracy and stuff like that and
people
by the way dress up as pirates i mean
it's yeah
yeah i mean it's it's its own thing you
know uh but you know if you look at
their early stuff so they're they're a
mid 80s or mid
1970s band at first um
they they form in 76 they don't actually
again they don't secure a record
contract until the mid 80s so they could
have broken out earlier but
the stars didn't align gates to
purgatory
branded and exiled those are not pirate
metal those are just sort of straight
ahead
power metal you know speed metal
whatever we want to call it from the mid
80s and then under jolly roger
well you know what that that's a pretty
easy one to you know
identify as the turning point so these
are these are some of the
big things that are happening there's
some other bands as well that are
important gravestone grave digger living
death
steeler stormwitch we should also talk
about warlock
um you know they they get formed in 82
out of some other bands that doro pesch
had had and
their stories kind of in some ways kind
of tragic actually i i
marked this thing from an interview so
doro
uh when she was asked about uh how it
was when she was starting out she said
in the 80s it was a little tricky
because i couldn't speak english and
neither could the band
i'd have an idea and i'd write lyrics
using a dictionary um
sometimes it was very funny once we had
a song called i'm the red light star
we went and played in england and some
journalist says yeah you have some
interesting lyrics
what is i'm the red light star about and
i said it was about going on stage and
feeling the lights on you and then he
said well
you know that's the red light here is
where the hookers go
and so you know there's that going on
and then later in that interview she
talks about
how how she became doral and the banduro
the um the european manager had been
screwing them over like taking the
t-shirt
sales um you know had written all sorts
of things into the contract that were
very binding and it was only when they
went on tour in america
in the 1980s uh mid-80s that the
american manager looked at he was like
this is a terrible contract
you got to get out of this somehow the
only way out of that contract
she said and this is in in a later part
of that interview
she said here we go
when i first started out i never thought
things could go wrong i used to think
everyone was our friend
i learned the hard way there's more to
the music business than those who love
it and we had to learn how to survive
without either our name or our
money we sold millions of t-shirts at
the time which made us the third biggest
selling merchandise band after metallica
and iron maiden
the manager took all the earnings and
made sure the band didn't get anything
and then she said um when we when we
broke off the european manager quit and
took away warlock's income and recording
budgets
so you know he even took their their
name they couldn't perform anymore under
their name
and so she had to become doro and
and start touring under that name it was
still the same band
but that was the only way that they
could make a living
by going off and and doing that but
she's she and and warlock are an
important part of that
that scene as well so you can see
there's a lot of
bands in the early in the late 70s
early 80s starting to make their mark a
lot of them
i would say you know the ones that are
known over here at that time would be
except
warlock and the scorpions but there's a
lot of stuff happening
within um the german scene and those
germans are
some of them able to get over here to
the states they're definitely touring
around europe
and definitely going to britain as well
so we have the the formation of
something like a solid you know
metal network you could say yeah
but um yeah well i feel like doro
is uh more popular in the states than
warlock
you know i i you know that's probably a
function of the renaming
right she was she was touring in the
states more
under doro and and certainly for a lot
longer
right yeah i mean um if you ask somebody
about doro they you know they know
we're like yes the the diehards know
warlock
yeah but you know i saw doro a few years
ago with one
with my friend and she was fantastic it
was great show worth every penny
um she's great she just she gave like
150 percent
and i told greg this yesterday which was
kind of interesting
um she was really sick that night but
sang great performed great
but she waited for about two and a half
hours and didn't leave until
everybody got their picture with her or
uh she signed everything and said hello
to anybody that wanted to say hi to her
which i thought was pretty impressive
you know she comes over here
yeah dates and plays these clubs and um
is fine
you know where and i what i thought of
is like the whole meet and greet thing
at 250 bucks to get a picture
well she didn't charge anything she came
out and you know waited and signed and
took pictures and i thought that was
pretty
you know uh it conveys a certain ethos
uh a connection to
the fans um a seriousness about the
the music and the experience you could
say right yeah and it's not it's not
being commercialized like when kiss does
stuff
right you know yeah well you get what
you pay for
um but uh i guess
you know greg and i were discussing um
you know purchasing i purchased a
michael shanker live album
and i showed greg yesterday i said
here's the thing it was only like
it wasn't that much money but it was a
double cd and a dvd
and like i feel like uh if you're a
metal fan
the metal bands give you a lot for your
money right
right yeah and um a country artist as
well but
um but maybe that's why metal bands are
selling um well you had mentioned like
well you can't
just go to apple music and see the dvd
like you'd have to buy that package to
get the dvd of it
although you can listen to it on all
right apple music so
i think this is a big thing and um
yeah with the metal bands it's like they
very much appreciate
the fans but like you know that when i
saw doro do that i i said to my friend i
said i can't believe this
you know this is this is there's
something else in in the interviews that
i was like pouring through
that i think is connected to this
and it's it's an interview with real
schechner who's somebody who i
i really admire because i kind of think
that
um you know no rudolph schenckner no
scorpions it doesn't matter how
great you know michael schechner or
ulivan roth or matthias jobs
r as guitarists or you know they've had
some great bassists as well
um i think that you know rudolph
schenker he's so absolutely central to
the the music writing process and he's
also
you know like so michael schechner is
always like oh rudolph sucks and that's
why he hangs back and i think it's
actually more of a humility thing
he's he's fine playing um rhythm guitar
he does play solo on a few
songs but he's interested in he's sort
of like the um
the steve harris you know with iron
maiden
although steve harris is an incredibly
talented bassist uh steve harris is
also the guy who makes sure that
everything goes the way it's supposed to
go
and the music is done the right way and
he's the band leader
and i think that that's rudolph
schenckner so he
said in this this uh interview um
he's saying uh
the situation is and he's talking about
their success
if you trust your feelings and you
really have a philosophy then you can do
it
because the problem is mostly from the
american english bands they're mostly
okay let's come together let's play
music let's see what's happening
so in america and england there are
managements big managements telling you
mostly not the truth they're telling you
some
let's say believe what you like to
believe and then he says
when we started the scorpions in germany
i did the management so nobody could
tell me
you know what to do nobody could tell me
what's true and what's not i decide by
for myself what the truth is
and then he said from this moment down i
noticed what i had to do to make the
career the band
first of all the banned scorpions is
based on the
philosophy of friendship i was always
looking for good musicians no question
about this
but for musicians who i could build a
friendship with
which chemistry wise links into my
personality and he goes on in the
interview to you know bring this up a
couple more times that friendship
has to be a central part of it now he's
talking there about like the intra band
stuff you know
the different players and that's that's
really important you know
um i'll bring up an example of something
very different than that
having to do with accept in a moment um
that andy and i observed when we saw
them i think it was in 2014 or so
on the blind rage tour um but i think it
could also extend to the fans
you know it's very easy to say stuff
like oh you know
uh you you look down at the monitor you
know oh milwaukee we love to be here
so wonderful right and you don't have
any clue where the hell you are
you know how's everybody doing tonight
you know all that sort of patter
it's a whole different thing to connect
with fans
on a personal level even if it's only
just for you know a minute each fan
it's it's something it's something quite
different um
going back to the the intra-band thing
you know when we saw
uh accept it was really it was a great
show
except for something shameful that was
happening on stage
which was that um you know they had
herman frank as the
the second guitarist along with uh wolf
hoffman and wolf hoffman was basically
like
just bullying him on stage i mean
there's something clearly going on and
then
frank and the drummer at the time quit
soon afterwards um and it was uh
you could tell like there was no you
know for
hoffman he was the key person and there
really wasn't room for anybody else on
the stage
you know and subsequently hoffman and
baltis
couldn't even stay together you know um
and so it's interesting too i'll mention
another
thing about hoffman so
udo dirk schneider said that um
without realizing it they signed their
ways into contracts where hoffman got
the
the name except and he got a lot of the
the other stuff that goes along with it
uh in part because hoffman's wife by
then
was was their manager um and so you know
when you do stuff like that
it's kind of dirty pool and it's gonna
break up
it's going to turn everything into a
professional relationship rather than a
a a friendly relationship you know
and you know uh just from um
this is a great philosophy because we
have a or i have a saying or
anybody here that's a musician that
performs we have a we have a thing and
it's like
you know i have my band i'm i'm going to
hire a bass player and all this
but the um the big question that we
kind of joke about is can we spend six
months
on a tour bus with this person without
killing each other
right so um you know and i learned at a
young age that it's not always the best
player that gets the gig
because you might have somebody that's
absolutely fantastic but not a good
person
yeah that will lead to problems down the
road so you get a very good player
um that's very musical or whatever but
um
i think what you uh i love the quote you
got from rudolph that
um he had the right mindset for the
beginning because like if this is going
to be successful
you know we need to get along and
usually you know i i haven't heard that
in the context of a band as much because
we always hear bands fighting but
yeah they say you have like well doro
like if she hires her band
you know part of the thing she's gonna
say is can i deal with this guitar
player on
a nightly basis or on the tour bus or
and
that's a you know that's a very
important thing and that's a great quote
you found
i wasn't aware of that that he said that
yeah he he's
he's a surprisingly
thoughtful guy in a lot of these well i
shouldn't say surprisingly
why why should we be surprised that
somebody who could actually put together
a mega band and keep it together over
all these years
well because when we were kids we had
the you know like our
we see his picture and he's just like
playing the guitar yeah yeah yeah
so of course he's a rock star um
but that's a great thing you know it's a
great philosophy before a band
and yeah you know we talk about you know
in past episodes
with us you know on this we would talk
about okay when's the band not a band
anymore we've got two versions of this
band
two two versions of that band and um
you know like we talked about queens
reich like which is the wheel real
queens reich
right hate one or the or rat or sax
yeah uh oftentimes having to go to the
courts to
to decide these things um which is a
shame
but um you know i'll mention too there
there is one band who managed to do that
quite well
um and even with one of the
the members and you know
um sort of split off bands being a
self-proclaimed misanthrope and that's
algae ward
that's tank right there's two tanks out
there right now one of them is just
algae ward who can't tour anymore
and so he's got his own home studio and
he plays all the instruments and every
once in a while he drops a record you
know
and then there's the other tank which
goes
has uh evans and tucker as as the uh
two guitarists um and then they they
they sometimes swap out singers they had
doogie white for a while i'm not quite
sure who they have
really at present yeah yeah and and they
do the old tank songs but they also
produce
new stuff and both of them are producing
new things
they're both good you know um
yeah and apparently um as you know algae
ward
is as warm towards them as he can be
towards anybody which is not all that
much
um i mean if you look at the
relationship and accept between
so when they actually break up and udo
goes his own way
and then it's essentially um uh
hoffman and baltis um and and herman
frank who's not going to stay there that
long
himself anyway um you
you know it's it's not quite so it's not
super acrimonious
like it is with saxon but it's
there's no love lost between dirk
schneider and and hoffman that's for
sure
you know what a shame you know what we
call it
um deal always called it um
oh l g uh lgd
lead guitarist oh l lgs league guitar
syndrome syndrome yeah and then see he
must have had michael schechner and
and mine i wanted to you know since you
brought up dio
one of the other things that i found out
that was really quite interesting you
know when you
there there are some people when you
listen to interviews with them you're
like wow that's
that that person's really thoughtful and
they're
you know they're relating to the
interviewer they're being very honest
about the the rock and roll industry
and seeing what they have to say is
really quite interesting
who do dirk schneider is one of those
people guess who
udo dirk schneider hung out with and
took advice from ronnie james deal
i that warms my heart that is the best
story
you told me that yesterday yeah isn't
that i mean in a way it's not surprising
but in a way it's also kind of kind of a
cool thing to find out
you know i wonder how they met do you
know that i think it was uh
touring you know what but you know like
i don't you know not to like piggy off
this but
remember um we are start we're stars
hearing aid
yeah but that would have been like
mid-80s right
right so dio was the producer and he had
like you know don dawkin and all these
people and he was
directing all of them and dawkin and
all these singers would say you know
he'd suggest that they
do something else you know you have to
make it more like this yeah
each and every one of them said i got
that from you ronnie
like it was just i missed that at the
time but like if you look at it on
youtube
um the re you know there must have been
mad attitude in the
mid 80s with angvae there and all these
people
but everybody um everybody
did uh you know
kind of praise dio to his face
you know with dio i imagine that
given what you can tell from the
universe obviously i've never met the
guy in my life right so i haven't
interacted with him he's been dead for
10 years
um but you would imagine that
so he he would say something and then
maybe the singers
or guitarists or whoever the drummer
could be
pushes back because of ego and there's
one of two
there's one of three things you can do
at that point you can be like well [ __ ]
it i'm out of here i'm not going gonna
talk with this person
blah blah blah you know um i'm gonna go
sulk or you know i'll
remove them from the tour or something
like that another would be to like get
belligerent and argue with them about it
you know and try to turn it into a thing
and i imagine that i i suppose another
thing would be to give in to them which
i don't imagine d.o did either
and another would be to be persuasive to
be like listen i can see things from
your side
but here's what we need in this and the
bigger project is this and i you know
just
listening to him i imagine that dio was
probably
good at that kind of persuasion
you know and if you think about like who
dio came up
under first richie blackmore blackmore
would have been
one of those like fine you're off of the
tour you know right um
i think dio is was much more of a um
you know a good rhetorician and and you
know pragmatic about these sort of
things
yeah i mean like you know um in his
interviews he was always very
matter-of-fact
yeah you know i don't know if you ever
saw if anybody here has ever seen the
one
where um this guy gets on the tour bus
to interview him
oh right yeah and he hands him the
albums
in order and he'll go oh this is a great
record i remember this one
you know you know the sabbath or
whatever this is guard
this is garbage don't put your money on
that and like you know but he
but he never raised his voice he was
always like
very even-tempered things are in
proportion for him
yeah so he's like this is terrible and
he saves the theatrics for the stage
you could say right nobody better yeah
yeah
ultimately but like that's interesting
so um
there was a crossover with the german
bands i mean if if udo and him were
hanging that
that's you know i'd love to hear him
talk about dio you know another another
crossover
um you mentioned don dochen early
earlier on
dawkin came to germany and he was
involved with the production of the
blackout album
um klaus maya had had i forget exactly
what was wrong with his vocal cords but
he had even operation
and there were some worries about
whether he was ever really going to be
able to sing again
and so dawkin did the backing lyrics and
he also didn't
you remind me about this term the the
scratch
right so he he did that and then
klaus might have you know recovered and
and that was that
doc and you know went back to the states
um but for a little while it looked like
you know maybe he'd be uh involved with
scorpions in a significant way
i have to look into like i'll look into
that i wonder how he got involved
you know it's kind of like la to germany
kind of thing it's like you know yeah
um but you know i bet you those scratch
vocals exist somewhere
i bet you well you know one way in which
these bands would get to know each other
was and this is something i wanted to
talk about through
influence and touring right right so a
lot of these german bands are influenced
by
and they'll tell you straight out you
know like we listened to black sabbath
we listened to
deep purple like the scorpions when they
first started out they actually played
covers
of those bands um and so there's that
aspect but then there's the touring
right uh it wasn't just the beatles who
toured in germany
everybody else did too because the
germans did in fact
well the europeans in general liked
heavy metal and then the german bands
a small tour would be just in in like
germany
but then the bigger tours would take you
to
um france um belgium
netherlands maybe down into
italy depending on what's going on maybe
um through east germany over to berlin
right or towards the you know mid to
late 80s you could also like go behind
the iron curtain
and start start playing there actually
one of the things i wanted to bring up
about accept is um they
they got misidentified in two different
ways um
and kind of interesting and in one case
kind of funny
stuff so you know they they
wore a lot of military uniforms like old
cast off stuff they'd buy like a
whatever the german equivalent of
goodwill is right or
an army surplus store right and when
they that were that worked just fine for
germany
worked fine for the united states
england when they got to france
they've got a you know blond-haired
blue-eyed
shaven-head guy as their lead singer and
they're decked out in old german
uh regalia they got labeled as a nazi
band
and it actually cost them some tour
dates um
yeah until they got things straightened
out and um you know they they
you know like on some of their songs
they
would sometimes get booed uh because the
french
viewed them as as being nazi fascistic
however you want to
think about it the other thing that was
kind of funny was
i mentioned that that wolf hoffman's
wife was involved in some of the
songwriting
and as wolf hoffman has said in
interviews
um and also dirk schneider's back this
up
um some of the songs were written
essentially from
a woman's perspective about about guys
and um you know what are we talking
about there well you know female gays as
opposed to the male gays or
ways of describing things so except god
got labeled for a while
as being a uh gay metal band
and um that was yeah and
and you know they obviously in the in
the mid 80s they were trying to avoid
that sort of image i mean
nowadays it's it's not an issue at all
but it was it was kind of a
an interesting point there like you know
london leather boys right
uh off of the balls the wall album would
be one of the biggest ones that people
would center in
mark smith uh writes the intro to fast
as a shark where they say hi d
hi ho it was a problem uh
because it was it was a folk song
popular with the nazis or something like
that yeah
and they don't they also don't do it in
poland
that's another place where that does not
go over well so they
they learned from experience not to do
that um
well it's funny because going back to
the stay in
a state of life uh the live album from
85
the cover is udo on stage with the
military gear on yeah
uh that was japan okay
but uh i mean look look at the russian
roulette
um album cover right they're all in
military uniforms
that's right yeah yeah um you know
that that actually um
leads us into some some other things as
well
that we are going to talk about um
like you know the one one thing we do
want to hit on is why
why english why why is german metal
pretty much all
in english but we could we could talk
about other things that don't
before we do that there's a few other
things that that
represent you could say a different
cultural set of assumptions
and what i have in mind here is
emblemized in the scorpion's album
covers
like love drive for example right the
back cover of it
had um had a woman who was partially
naked on it and that ran into problems
in the united states and
in britain right and the the scorpions
were like
what's the problem with us you know
different different uh sets of cultural
assumptions about sexuality
and um you know so we can say that
there's there's a lot of
potential interference areas that right
that german metal bands had to to deal
with but
let's talk about the english thing right
so it's kind of an interesting thing to
think about
were they were they just being you know
like straight out mercenary and saying
listen we're gonna sell way more albums
if we do our songwriting in english
and and you know like doro like she said
didn't really
know what she was singing at the time
close minus says you know
i mean you listened to him like in
interviews in the 80s even now he's got
a
super thick accent we we used to have
these commercials
i don't know if they had him where you
grew up but there was one for like qfm
milwaukee it was klaus miner
and he'd be like hello milwaukee
you know i listened to qfm
you know you'd be like this guy doesn't
know english at all
in the 80s reading interviews and
i have it somewhere i kept it because i
felt like the
person interviewing him was super rude
so it was like
so it was like every time he stopped it
didn't know the word
he would say you know like around things
you'd throw things in like that you
don't want anymore
yeah you print that he goes a trash can
and he was like
yeah that's what it is but he you know
if you want to be a jerk as a journalist
you print everything
right right you can't get into trouble
for it but it's you know
but like every time klaus like and he
goes and you know
he'd make the side note klaus is very
frustrated or
you know um so he's doing this interview
and the the guy's angle was this guy
can't speak english and
i'll never forget that because you know
he was he spoke english fine but
you know he didn't know the words to
describe he was he was
talking about you know kind of like b
stock songs of the scorpions
yeah you know we throw him in the trash
but he would say what's that thing that
you
he was trying to like yeah yeah garbage
can and then
yeah um but you know i remember that
seeing that going
this is you know like it's one thing to
memorize a set of lyrics
and to belt it out i mean you're it's
repetition right you're singing the song
over and over and over again it's a
whole different way to hold a
conversation with somebody
um especially when you're like on a tour
and you're probably all strung out from
driving all over the place and yeah i so
you know
there were a few interesting things that
that again when i went to interviews
bands were saying um klaus mina in a
interview said is there anything german
in our music
i don't know that's a good question
obviously we're from
germany but we grew up with english and
american music which was a strong
inspiration
for us early on in the 70s we went to
england and france to japan
and america we toured and we became an
international band so
he's i mean if michael schechner group
is an international band because he
he's a german artist himself but he has
all sorts of other people
who are working with him who are not
german sort of like rainbow you know
rainbow is not a british band because
even though richie blackmore is he's got
all these other
people um i think you could say that
about the scorpions and then he
says i think our music was never german
it's always had this anglo-american
influence we never tried to be a german
band
um we are germans but not in our music
when we grew up there was schlager music
this pop music kind of thing and there
was a lot of german
you know um right uh music
in in german udo said something really
interesting in a recent interview
and he was asked well why why did except
do their stuff in english and he said
rock and roll has to be in english
and obviously that's not the case a
hundred percent but
he he went on to explain he said listen
you know rock and roll developed in
english
that is the language for it and then the
same
the interviewer said well you know that
gets you bigger distribution he's like
yeah that that's true too but
this is the real reason um so
it was as if you know you you would
express yourself and all you know all
these bands that we've brought up
and we mentioned about i think 10 or 15
bands they're all
in english you know um and they all made
the choice to do their their stuff
in english uh i don't think it was just
a
matter of let's get better distribution
um i think there was kind of a feeling
that
like what udo is expressing that
this is this is the way it's done you
know and you know of course you know
we had talked yesterday you can't take
um it's hard to take a song in english
and put it in another language because a
one-syllable word
with us might be three syllables in
another language
and then the the rhythm's off but we
talked about um
what do you call like uh saved we have
like uh
well like you got another thing coming
you you brought up so oh
right yeah where where they take a
not a cliche but but a common saying
yeah they transform it into um sometimes
they play around with it a little bit in
the wording
chris says metal transcends national
categorization perhaps consider this
finnish offspring
of german and english influences
and that is coronary
[Music]
says that they uh sound like an
offspring of except
and judas priest um yeah and a band
yeah yeah i mean and there's uh
there's another um there's another
finnish band
that in the 1980s it's just called oz
and so i think that may have been a
little problematic because
it's close enough to ozzie that people
could be like oh i've uh
i don't need to buy this i've already
heard it sort of like riot and quiet
riot riot was
a new york band and then you know quiet
riot
getting good essentially did them in um
oz was doing what sounds like new wave
of british heavy metal
in the early 80s in finland
you know and so there's a lot of
interesting uh
things like that and oz was singing in
english as well i mean almost everybody
sings in
english with the exception of
a few french bands um and then
and then they don't get big you know
because uh they're not getting the
distribution
that they they might have otherwise
gotten um
i'm blanking on the name of one that's
quite good sorcilesch
most of their songs are in french and
that i think
really significantly restricted them
but maybe there's also something about
composing in in english
you know i you know i was talking about
uh italian
singers that are here like in boston
and and when i hear the original stuff
it's
um it's mostly in english
and i said why don't you write in your
native language
and they're just kind of like well
that's the way it is you know like they
grew up with the
um uh english-speaking artists yeah
and that's kind of like um i mean even
like
one of the biggest italians pop stars
ever laura prasani
this is a italian i'm sorry she's an
italian artist
everything's in english and even though
she's huge in italy they all
she sings in italy in english so yeah
um i don't know the impact of the words
you know like look when you're writing
lyrics
you know there's certain sounds that
have a certain impact yeah yeah and for
metal yeah i think that's that's it's
harder
i i would you know i mean this is sort
of like being very speculative but i
would say it's probably harder to sound
metal
in french than it is english
you know well germany would be a good
metal language i think
like it's pretty aggressive sounding you
know that
when you hear people's thoughts i mean
if you're because there's all these
dialects right
um right so you know like uh
you know bavarian kind of kind of a soft
way of talking in many ways
that's that's where i learned my german
because that's where i was stationed
in the army mark says some japanese
bands take a median route
versus in japanese and then the chorus
in english i wonder if the germans
considered that option that's a really
interesting idea
um i mean japan has its own really
interesting metal thing and and in in
many respects you know thank god for
japan because there are so many bands
that if they didn't have japanese sales
they never would have been able to stay
afloat
you know that like when paul gilbert
went there
like paul gilbert in america would sell
out 200
c club yeah you know from racer x and mr
big but
um my friend actually played second
guitar for him and he went to japan
and when he came back he said we were
playing 20 000
seaters i killed paul gilbert 20 000
seeders he's like
i swear to god yeah and it's
you know it's it's interesting how the
you know metal is so embraced in in
japan
yeah i mean there's the old sort of like
joke you know big in japan right and
nobody's heard of you anywhere else
um and you know there's all those cool
japanese like for us they're they're
import albums
they'd just be pressed in japan for
japanese people
right um well that's right they always
get the
the main pit right so i mean there's all
this stuff that we just
you know never had access to by the way
mentioning quiet riot
one of the things that did kind of hurt
them was that their
first two albums were only released in
japan
not in the united states i didn't even i
didn't know that
yeah i mean that's i mean if you're an
la club band that's probably not
a a great um now
admittedly their first two albums were
actually not very good too
um so this was mental health the first
one that
came out here then what was that yeah
yeah
yeah 82 or 83 yeah i want to say 83 but
me too yeah so
what else i mean there was one other
thing that i wanted to bring up that i
thought was kind of cool
that some people might not know about
and it's almost like trivial and then
let's let's open it up just as a
question and discussion
so there there was a uh an album called
a split
album and i i didn't know about this
until i started digging around and a
split album is not a compilation because
a compilation
you've only got one song from
each band that's on it like metal
killers collection or those who remember
back in the 80s masters of metal that
was another really great metal
uh compilation so a split album is where
you have
you know anywhere from like three to
five bands and they
all record tracks for that album
they go in as a partnership have it
pressed have it released they all share
in the earnings
there was a a split album by death metal
that um was by the band's halloween
hellhammer running wild and dark avenger
and it's the only recorded material of
that band dark avenger
um it's kind of a cool thing you don't
you don't see that happening
a lot in the united states you know
this this split album phenomenon um
so you know um what do you what do you
make of that scott or
whatever what does everyone else make of
that phenomenon well i mean it was news
to me when you told me because
of course you know what a compilation is
you previously
recorded music and just you know
uh we take these two songs from this
band's album and this other band's album
and then what they do to make it even is
they master it for that album so
the um um
the the levels are correct so it's not
like you if one song is loud and the
next song's off
now this whole thing about bringing
bands in i mean
there's a few things i mean
who front which record company fronts
the money i'm curious so if it's like
you got somebody on columbia you got
somebody on this label
who so what record company ends up
putting it out
who's front of the money who recoups the
money and
is it more of a the bands agree to do it
because they'll gain an
audience piggybacking off of the other
it's kind of like
hey greg you have some fans i have some
fans let's do a collaboration
and maybe your fans will come to me and
my fans will come to you
but it's pretty interesting that they've
written
they they're re writing and producing
music specifically for
an album that they know that there's
gonna be other bands so
how do you pick the sequence of the
songs how do
i have a lot of really good questions
because i've never it was always like
k-tell right
so like yeah um
album going back to the like the um so i
think some of the bands would be on the
same level and collaborating with each
other
like in this case you know running wild
is pretty established
hellhammer where i think it was pretty
established halloween was was just
getting going
dark avenger is getting kind of brought
along for the ride so it might be the
sort of thing that you do where you're
like i want to help promote
these these other bands without having
to like produce an entire
ep or or even lp for them um the way
that we saw like in the american setting
right we're
established artists like gene simmons
were saying
i want to produce van halen's album or
right
things like that yeah yeah um maybe they
did share
uh producing expertise too you know i i
that's
that's that's something that i don't
know um
you know sister brought up i'm gonna
look into it so i'll
you know i have a lot of questions um
because it's just like
a logistical nightmare i mean
maybe but maybe it wasn't back then
maybe maybe that's why it could happen i
mean nowadays you're right
um especially with the really strong
conceptions of ip that we have
um right maybe back in the day it was
easier to do
you know in the mid 80s and who got the
idea and who
how are the bands picked and i'd love to
hear about the whole process because
until you brought that up i wasn't aware
of that kind of
split album you know yeah i don't
remember owning any you know so mark
says he's come across stuff like that in
black metal so maybe
um where there's associations between
bands and they're connected with each
other for
uh you know a while um maybe tour
together or stuff like that
that becomes more feasible
more of a collaboration i would say so
like you know
if you and i were going to put an album
out together but we're on different
labels
yeah um yeah i'm gonna have to look into
that and um
that's really fascinating like i would
love to know
how that works how it comes about i
could see the benefit from it
i think it's a good uh yeah because look
you know like
okay so i love two of these bands the
other two i don't know who it is
and it's kind of like i think i told you
um i told was telling greg yesterday
that
when accepts metalheart came out
i i used to go to tower records in
boston and with every purchase you've
got a 45
of two tracks uh from metalheart
and so i don't remember what album i
bought i remember they put a 45 in there
and said this is free
and then i went home and wore out the 45
and i went and actually
bought metal hearts so it's like you
know these are good promotional tools
um you know i want to hear what else is
on that album or yeah that's sort of
like a little sampler right
it's a sampler but like same with the
collaboration album it's kind of like
well
i've never heard of this band but i
really like them i'm gonna
maybe that's the deal with the record
companies is like we don't care
we're gonna go in because we're gonna
all promote these bands
and maybe the band on our label will
sell more records if they agree to be on
um what's like you you see um on metal
albums if they have a guest like
adrian vandenberg was on the white snake
album you know he appears courtesy of
this record company um and of course the
record companies are thrilled to get
their name
on other labels in the credits
um so that could be part i don't know
how the
the business worked at the time with
that but it's certainly it's great
i mean as a fan um that's the kind of
record i would want to buy remember when
we were younger yeah
we threw a care to the wind i love this
band i've never heard this record i'm
buying it and you just listen
well you you might buy it too in part
because you already know the
you know one or two well-established
bands then you're like well this other
stuff you know
must be good if they're on there as well
yeah
and then yeah i mean look you know um
as you said earlier today uh being uh
discovering bands how did we do it it
was a mixture of things but the
compilations you know
even the compilation records it's like
wow you know this
i've never heard of this band but this
song is like with except i really liked
um
screaming for a love bite was on that
album okay and that was the b
side i think metalheart was on a
but i i liked that song so much and you
know that
prompted me to buy their record yeah
fast as a shark was on metal killer's
collection
volume one um and i think that
may have been the first except song that
i heard
um pretty soon after that i had balls to
the wall
and um i started buying other other
except stuff but
that was yeah those those those
collections and interestingly too a lot
of those collections did not sell well
i would often get them in the bargain
bin at target
right that form you know that's right
the the cutouts
right they would like with the cut out
yeah oregon bin yeah of course that's
actually how i got
this is a total side note here and then
let's open this up for
you know questions and and all that um
ac dc's flick of the switch
really really good album got panned you
know
and it was in part because ac dc had
done such great stuff before that
and flick of the switch was trying to
return to a more raw
sound i thought it was excellent i got
it for like a buck 99 at target
you know and then you know played it and
played it and i remember
people at school were like oh you got
the one ac dc album that's no good you
know and i was like
you're full of it you know that's right
yeah you know what that's true and
that's talk about courage
to go to school but we always talk about
that right don't wear the wrong metal
shirt
and then the punks versus the metal
heads and yeah
yeah but like you know there's to say i
really like this album oh
that's the dumb one that's the one we
don't like and uh that was a great that
was very good
i had a guy who did that actually and he
was he was somebody who i thought was
full of crap anyway
um i had uh i used to bring my boombox
to school
and uh i had judas priest sin after sin
which i
also bought in a bargain rack down down
in in spring break in florida
and he's like oh you got the one judas
priest album that sucks and i was like
this doesn't suck
but i think a lot of it is is um you
know like
people had their fixed ideas you know
and and then they just kind of
kind of ran with them but let's let's
open this up to any any
further questions or discussion i want
to be respectful of people's time
um we're getting close to an hour and a
half already
um any other
topics you know you heard me mention
or scott mentioned a band you're like
who are those guys you know
i mean until then i'll actually make one
recommendation there is a band out there
called sinner and
it included herman frank who is is later
going to go to accept by the way herman
frank is putting out some really really
great stuff
from like 2016 on
every year he's putting out a great
classic album
um but it was formed by this uh vocalist
and bassist matt
sinner who then later on is going to
join primal fear
so if you know later metal you know and
you like stuff that sounds a lot like
judas priest primal fear is
is that banned sinner um consistently
put out some great albums uh wild and
evil in 82
fast decision in 83 danger zone 84
touch of sin 85 coming out fighting in
86 and these were all on
noise records you can't actually get the
albums
as such on apple music but you can get a
compilation
of like the best of those the noise
record years
so that that's you know if you want one
obscure german band to listen to that
might be the one
but here we go marx's first thing i'm
doing after this is looking up trance
they're good i i was pretty impressed
with the stuff
kakumen not so much you know
um chris has got a uh
thing about uh german doom metal from
this year
uh that is he's uh
giving us a link to here um and
that's a good question about the
scorpions yeah i don't i don't know
anything about it
um i saw them ago but they did they
weren't touring an album
they were just on tour playing um
i mean what was the one with um
the 90s one is the last one i remember
with um
well they've put out some some albums
since then i i
i wonder how much covid has thrown a
monkey wrench
not just into touring but even album
production because so
for you know a lot of these guys in
these bands
right they're living in different areas
they can't easily get together to
jam start working on album ideas
practice then get into the studio but
now that
now that we have vaccination i think
there's going to be a lot of not only
resumption of tours
which is very important making money for
these fans of course
because they're not making a ton of
money on albums um
but uh yeah they
we should probably see a lot of new
albums coming out i imagine
i'll go ahead sorry i just want to um
something you said that's very important
um there's the new way of making records
which is
you know uh i'll play guitar part with a
click
track send it to you you add your bass
right right but you're talking about
the way these bands record and it's you
can tell
that they're playing together you know
yeah
the bass player the drummer have worked
together for years
and like joe walsh says like now
nobody's testifying
you know joe walsh is like the old
records we love like the way
all these bands did these records
because they played at the same time
and there was a certain energy in the
room and you record the phoenix
and maybe fix the vocals but um i think
it's important what you said because i
think
bands like the scorpions aren't going to
be into
okay we'll send it to klaus or send it
to you know and then like you know
they'll
they they they were very much uh the
process back then was you get into a
room
and what if we added this part or um and
they would discuss it so what you're
saying
actually for these classic bands is the
process
that they're used to with two inch tape
no digital i mean
look 70s and 80s and even part of the
90s you had to play it right there was
no digital editing there was no auto
tune
there was no uh your performance was
your performance
yeah well i think this is the process
that we enjoy in the old record you know
um i think too that
so you like look at how bands
start up new projects right except got
back together
because because this is in the early
2000s um
uh wolf hoffman and peter baltes were
like let's
let's just hang out we'll drink some
beers and jam
you know and then they're like oh maybe
this could turn into an album you know
uh
and apparently like udo and peter baltus
were doing some stuff
fairly fairly recently like before kovid
started oh wow
um and so that could turn into something
who knows you know
um herman frank has been like i
mentioned turning out some really great
stuff recently
as well um yeah and so
there's there's that and then there's
like you know some of the like really
big festivals those are also occasions
where bands
will try out new songs or or you know
um they'll make connections right
they're walking around and they
meet up with old old band mates and
they're like hey should we try this you
know
let's bring up this guy on stage or
something like that
so i think as as things open up we'll
see
more of that happen again we're we're
it's we're kind of in a situation where
everything's on hiatus right
um until that happens mark has a good
question for
you what do you think of bands like
scorp yeah scorpions re-recording old
material
do you think it improves the sound the
song quality
um you want to see anything oh um well
my take is this
um so like let's say for example
by the way a lot of bands re-record
stuff because they've lost
the rights to the album oh but they
still own their publishing so like great
white
did the first album again because the
record company said
we have 100 of the sales you signed it
away so
great white records as close as they can
30 years later
their first album so with the scorpions
my take on it is
if they were to try to do blackout now
it wouldn't be the same
because um that album was recorded
um i i think of it as as a screenshot of
that part of your life
and you capture it on an album and
you get 10 years wiser maybe but
the young um
the young uh what do you call like
getting uh the attitude
like you know maybe you've hung the
being hungry too you know
hungry and it's kind of like you could
play the parts but you're not gonna it's
not gonna sound like when you were 18
because you're not 18 anymore and so i
don't think
you know not to say like we don't want a
live album of them doing the classics
but to go in and actually try to
recreate the record well technology's
changed
yeah the circumstances were what they
were we joke about the white lion album
pride how it's it sound like it was
recorded in a trash can
but the songs were so good i listened to
it all the time when i was younger
but like if they went and said oh we're
gonna do like a really good version of
it well
um that was the version that's what it
is
um so as far as bands re-recording
albums so they
make money from the sales that makes
sense but for me
it's not blackout era anymore that's 40
years ago
almost and um that album you
you can't do it again i mean you can
play the parts you can
but um you're a different person so
that's a i love
chris i love that question actually mark
i'm sorry i love that question a lot
because um i think about that often it's
kind of like
i've heard some of these bands i'm like
ah but it doesn't give me that same when
the song was brand new at the time right
scorpion's like
excited like we got this new album black
out in this great song and they're so
sick to be in the studio
now they've been on the road for 40
years playing that album going eh
so we're going to play it again i think
i think there's some some challenges too
with some of the bands where
the um you don't have the same players
you know you have some of the main
players but yeah you have like the same
drummer
or uh good point bassist or
rhythm guitarist you know it's true and
you don't have the same gear
that gear is probably long gone and this
is just you know
from an artistic perspective it's kind
of like you know
going to an actor um going to jodie
foster when she was in taxi well why
don't you do that again
not a 16 year old girl anymore you know
yeah
yeah that'd be kind of funny to put
together like a classic movie with all
these old people you know doing doing
their lines again
you know yeah you know i'm gonna i'll
mention something too so
and then we'll we'll take uh chris's um
question um andy and i got to see
udo and accept the same year
uh udo was at the chance in poughkeepsie
which is kind of
it's like a bar that's uh also got a big
you know stage and stuff but it's pretty
small pretty intimate
and then we saw except with raven down
at the gramercy
in in the new york city also a fairly
small venue you know
um but with with seating and stuff like
that and
it was very interesting to see these two
bands
led by you know members who are very
original very
much part of the thing playing the same
songs
and doing their own thing with it
obviously the singers you know mark
tornillo and
and udo sound quite different um udo had
surrounded himself
with some really amazing talent young
young guys you know in their 20s and 30s
who were doing a great job um and could
do
like the sounding like the the classic
except
um but you know some of the same
songs balls to the wall they both did
that you know um fast as a shark they
both did that you know
and it was interesting to compare the
two
you know yeah i would love to see both
of those too and
um well you got the uno's voice which is
yeah so important and his stage presence
he you know there's some people who are
really performers
you know like udo ryan james deal bruce
dickinson
yeah you know um even even some who are
kind of idiosyncratic like richie
blackmore right i mean
richie blackmark scowls at people he's
he's not going to engage with the
audience but that's his shtick
yeah yeah exactly or
another great person is with massive
stage presence d snyder
you know oh yeah about him right um
well let's take chris's question uh any
comment on the genre term
kraut rock and he's got a reference here
to in trance which the the entry in
wikipedia says that
the scorpions were moving away from
their earlier
kraut rock thing and i you know i don't
know these music genres myself quite
quite so well
um kraut is as in the derogatory term
for
german so it links to this saying a
broad genre of experimental rock
uh artist blending elements of
psychedelic rock electronic music and
avant-garde composition among other
courses i mean i don't i don't think
that lonesome dove
or one that i just mentioned right after
it actually fit that
if if electronic music is supposed to be
part of it
um lonesome dove is you know it's
the psychedelic stuff is there um but
they're not using like you know
a lot of keyboard stuff or fly to the
rainbow yeah it's it's more like
the scorpions are developing out of a
jazzy
mixing psychedelic stuff along with a
heavier and heavier sound
but you know i think if i remember right
a lot of the kraut rock stuff
what weren't they singing more in german
than in english
you got me i mean this is a new term for
me
um but i know i have the the thing open
i'm reading and listening to you
yeah yeah um interesting
and that what a classic album cover
that's uli's guitar
i don't know if anybody's looking at the
blank but um the woman on the cover
that's uli john roth's guitar yeah
this i think they say it's a strat oh
yeah it's a 70 strike you can tell by
the
it's been doctored a little but so that
was 76
oh my gosh yeah
all right wow what i mean
any we could talk about like broader
german music we did that a bit already
in terms of like um
the choice to use english um being part
of
i guess you could say that you know
german heavy metal by being heavy metal
well you know and we also said too like
probably until
late 70s they're not they're not they're
not conceptualizing themselves as heavy
metal
um they're just conceptualizing
themselves as heavier and heavier and
harder
stuff that's that's rock you know rock
and roll
as a close mind would say um
and not and you know not doing things uh
the way that
a more specifically german
um orientation would would be you know
i mean a lot of german pop is just in
german you know
right yeah i mean yeah
i mean i should say though there's
there's quite a few other german bands
that are that are doing stuff in english
you think about fury in the
slaughterhouse
they'd be an example they chose to
i think they did do some stuff in german
though too
well you know we were talking yesterday
that um
the one time it was cool when uh in the
early 80s
uh that german singer nina did not right
yeah
but then it was so successful they put
out the german version of it
oh is that is that the story that the
english version
preceded the german version in this
country it did
oh okay i get it yeah and this country
did and then it was so popular
it was kind of cool if you knew how to
like say it in german
so they remember they released the 45
and the people in school would be like i
have the german version like that was
like
kind of a badge of honorable time here's
a really
great question from chris what is the
most
iconic scorpion song rocky like a
hurricane
so it depends on which scorpions you're
into
but if you're if you're i think for a
lot of people
and that's not a song i actually like
winds of change
right really that's the scorp that's the
scorpions that everybody knows across
the world as
and they were part of a really important
historical moment
right i'm not really that into
that stuff rocky like a hurricane
um that that's definitely one that i
think you could say
is iconic in that way
um the zoo
got a lot of radio airplay in in the 80s
you know that riff you know
done you know don and i i think there's
a lot of people who know how to play
that one
what else i mean if it were the early
scorpions probably speedy's coming
the only era you mean yeah yeah yeah i
mean that's that got a lot of radio
airplay too
those are completely different um eras
of the band
although i either i like them both you
know no of course
they're amazing i'll say something
unpopular but i really
like average amusement okay i thought
the
you know the songs were fantastic don't
stop at the top
the album opens with and i just uh the
rhythm of love was was getting a lot of
error play off of that one right that
was the hit
yeah and um i remember i bought that
tape that year and everybody was
go going back to you know people say you
got the stupid album you got the
that's the worst one you know like yeah
i you know i remember that summer it was
just on repeat in my
in my car um of course worldwide live is
my
uh go-to um yeah i mean um
like coming home that's a great opener
um and then coming home is off of love
at first thing right
yes or or isn't it yeah it is it is yeah
um
big city nights too big oh god you know
what
that one is up there for me yeah um
i mean blackout got a lot of airplay
dynamite
another another really big one well we
should also you know we could also say
i think for some people the balance
right
um still loving you holiday
holiday um this is an older one when the
smoke is coming down
no one like you that's a good one mark
oh that yeah
yeah that's off of blackout too right
great
oh yeah and it's still you know it's
great as we still hear it on the radio
yeah it's and you know when it comes on
like
uh the guitar so yeah you can if you
were gonna do name that
tune right you could just hear that that
one single guitar
note played that way and you'd be like
you know no one like you you know
that's right yeah you can name that in
one note
yeah old show so um
oh god but like when worldwide live came
out that was 85 also
i i still have my copy it's worn to hell
it's just
yeah i played it so much but um i used
to crank it up and
you know or put it in headphones if it
was late
you know i'm gonna tell a story and then
uh
scott'll maybe tell another story and
then we'll bring it to a close here
i had um a boom box that
had the cassette player that could like
switch back and forth you know like you
play the whole tape
and i had a 45 minute tape with love at
first sting on one
side and black out on the other side and
i would go to sleep with that that was
my like go to sleep music
and some people oh that's so hard and
heavy but actually the scorpions are so
melodic
even when they are being dissonant and
um
stuff like that i found uh it was like
my soporific
you know i would plug that in and
usually i would start on the love it for
sting side
and then you know if i made it to
blackout i
would just like sit there in the dark
and listen to it and slowly drift off
you know i couldn't do that with other
things like say iron maiden or deo or
judas priest
you know but the scorpions i could
definitely do that with
yeah i mean it's um you write about the
melodic part but you know
i think we discussed this in the past
it's kind of um
i could with iron maiden um
i could with something it's kind of like
well you know meditation's about
calmness and quiet but i think with uh
maybe we should talk about like you know
what metalheads have in common why we
have such an emotional response
well a lot of times i don't find it as
aggressive i find it as occupying
my racing mind maybe when i was in high
school right i was worrying about so
much
and if i put that on i had to focus um
and it was like it quieted my mind and i
could fall asleep although music
and um i i so you had the auto reverse
one
that's what it was called right auto
reverse yeah yeah
see i was doing the klaus mind thing
what is that thing where the tape
it goes both sides and right
um no i mean a cheap trick live at
buddhicon was one of them
i used to go to sleep but you know there
was always i always had
the tape recorded next to my bed and i'd
have some you know
i go to sleep to something always i mean
we had the 90 minute tapes for this
45 minutes aside like greg's saying so
you have
an hour and a half but i guess yours
kept going back and forth
yeah until unless i'd like wake up and
then hit hit stop
or anything like that i mean if it was
if it was uh with batteries of course it
would run down
pretty quick right usually i had it
plugged in
exactly yeah yeah well
um oh mark says something really funny
here this is a good thing to go out
it is heavy metal asmr you know
yeah it was kind of like that you know
and and what scott was saying
you know in a way the
not aggressivity but the i know the
hardness the heaviness of the stuff
for some of us that was not off-putting
it would it would kind of suck you in
and calm you down and cool you off
you know in in different ways um
maybe something to explore in another
another discussion so
yeah that's how i view it anyway yeah
any last words scott that you want to
say or um
i really enjoyed this session you know i
greg
brought this topic up and um it's
something that i didn't actually
consider
and of course him and i do some trading
as far as check this band out check out
this and we get these cool discussions
um
so i'm always uh i'm always excited to
kind of
learn a little more hear some new bands
and then kind of kind of consider that
it makes you re-evaluate the history of
music where did this come from
even down to the the story the cool
story that greg said about
udo and dio hanging out it's kind of
like well now this is coming together
even more so it's
i think these are you know as far as i'm
concerned very important discussions
about
you know stuff we didn't know from back
in the day
um thank you mark yeah thanks
thanks everybody and um i'm not sure
what we're gonna do for next session but
we'll we'll figure it out by
will yeah the next month from now and uh
we will hit the other german stuff
and and other european stuff down the
line as well so
have a great day everybody good good uh
evening to mark
good uh yeah mark afternoon to everybody
else
everyone yeah
you